-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy Award-winning
co-host of "CBS Mornings,"
host of the SiriusXM show
"Gayle King in the House,"
and the editor-at-large
of "Oprah Daily."
The winter issue
of "O Quarterly,"
which features this year's list
of Oprah's Favorite Things
is on newsstands now and
available at OprahDaily.com.
Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend
Gayle King, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show.
-I'm so glad to be here!
-I'm so excited to talk
about Oprah's Favorite Things,
but I do want to ask about
a couple of big interviews.
And of course, you do
a lot of big interviews,
but a couple of music legends --
Jay-Z, Barbra Streisand.
-I know, Seth.
All in the same week.
-That's amazing.
-I'm thinking, you know, guys,
you have a job where you go,
"just pinch me."
I really had a week.
And I did them both
in the same week in October,
and they're both from Brooklyn.
What does that mean?
Brooklyn!
[ Cheering ]
-And Barbra Streisand,
not the easiest interview
to land or do.
-No, Barbra Streisand,
her new book is out now.
The title is
"My Name Is Barbra."
And make sure you say
her name right.
It's not "Strei-sind,"
it's not "Streisan."
It's "Strei-sand,"
like beach on a sand.
She's very particular
about that.
And she told us back in the day
that they wanted her
to change her name to "Sydney."
She was thinking about "Sydney."
They thought Sydney
would be a stronger name.
She said, "I cannot do that,
but I will change the spelling."
So it's "Bar-bra."
So she did do that.
-That's lovely.
-She's amazing.
Well, that's so cool
that you did that.
-Her memoir is close
to a thousand pages.
I know it's a long read,
but it's a good read.
But she really does take you
through her life.
And I was just so thrilled
that she said, you know,
everybody was like,
"Pick me, pick me, pick me."
And I really was,
"Pick me, pick me."
And she said yes.
-That's really cool.
Jay-Z, too. Jay-Z.
Don't we love Jay Z?
[ Applause ]
Yes, we do!
I adore this man.
And it started because
the Brooklyn Library has,
you can go see it now
until December 4th,
his birthday.
It's called "The Book of Hove,"
and it takes you through
his career from the time
he was a teenager to where
he is now, a business mogul.
And I asked him, you know,
"I would love to go
see the exhibit
and do a walk and talk.
He said, "That's a good idea."
I go, "No, with you."
-Oh, yeah.
-"No, no, not by myself.
With you."
-Well, very smart.
You're a very good interviewer.
-No, I'm finding, Seth,
groveling really, really,
can be very effective.
I'm not kidding.
Oprah said to me,
"Stop asking him, Gayle.
He doesn't want to do it.
You're embarrassing yourself."
But I just thought
it was such -- number one,
and he rarely does interviews.
He's one of those
rare people like Taylor,
Bruce Springsteen, Beyonce.
They don't have to do anything,
because we're all coming.
-Yes.
-It's true.
They don't have to do anything.
We're coming.
But if there ever was a time
to do the interview,
I guess his team convinced him.
I don't know.
I'm just grateful
that he did it.
But to get to see
from his own words
what he was thinking
when different songs came out
and his writing process.
And you know,
where Blue got her name.
And he was really lovely.
Really, really.
-I'm going to ask him
to do my podcast.
-Yeah.
-No, no, no, I mean, we had
so much stuff on the floor.
We were only supposed
to have 45 minutes.
He gave us 2 hours.
You know what that's like.
-Yeah.
So we did
a primetime special last week,
and you can still get it
on Paramount Plus.
Have you seen it yet?
-I'm very excited to see it.
-I'm very proud of it.
-Oh, well,
I'm very excited to see it.
I'm very excited to see
some of the items this year
on this annual list.
-Me, too!
-And there's one --
we talked last year.
you tried to focus
on small businesses,
Black-owned businesses,
women-owned businesses.
-We have brand names too.
-Yes, of course.
-We run the gamut.
-But there was a product,
one of the products this year,
you had a real opportunity
to test out.
-I did, I did.
Because look at me, Seth.
Does my skin look glowy to you?
-It always has.
But this year, best ever.
-Audience, does my skin
look glowy to you?
-Best ever.
That's because I have
Dew Revive.
You know, my makeup artist,
Rae Dawn Brooks.
I'm very lucky. I have
hair and makeup every day.
I don't wake up this cute.
It takes a village.
But it's a body balm
for your face and your body,
whether you have eczema,
whether you have sunburn,
whether you just want smooth,
glowy, dewy skin, as do you.
-Thank you.
-As do you.
-I do want it.
-Okay.
-So I have this just for you.
Dew Revive just for you.
-Thank you so much.
-You're welcome.
-Alright.
-These are cool.
-Phaidon Press, which does
really cool, beautiful books.
Tell us about these.
These are art books for kids.
-But just open up
a couple of pages,
because it really
is works of art,
but they put it in kids' terms.
-Yes, that's very good.
-So it's like, okay, rainbow
happy and sticker explosion.
I know. Aw, it's so nice.
I have a favorite grandson,
Luca.
I'm getting him the whole thing.
He's only 2 1/2.
He can't read yet, but when he
can, this is going to be good.
You have
little ones at your house.
-I do, yeah,
and they like books.
-And they can read?
-They can read, yeah.
These are beautiful dolls.
-Now I like this,
because this is
Alimrose Halle Ballerina dolls.
When Serena had her baby,
you know,
she already has
an older daughter, Olympia,
and whenever a new baby comes,
it's always good to get
the older sibling something.
So I got this for Olympia,
but you can get this size,
and then you could get
a little baby version,
so I got both of them.
And the beauty of this is
it comes in
all different skin tones.
So, you know, dark skin,
light skin,
it's something for everybody.
I just think they're adorable.
-You know what we got my oldest
when our second was born?
-What?
-A job.
[ Laughter ]
We were like,
"Free ride's over, buddy."
-And what are they doing?
-They work for the city.
Wait, did you have something
down there?
The Pride + Groom tool?
-Because I was thinking
about Frisbee.
-Oh, is this for dogs?
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-Frisbee is Seth's dog, guys.
-Yeah.
-So Naomi Watts has this.
it's a total grooming kit
just for your dog.
So it's a --
-And the dog can figure out
how to use it on their own?
-No, no, no.
-Okay.
-You know when
you're bathing Frisbee,
you can have
a latherless shampoo
and stuff to clip their nose,
to make their fur, you know --
because those of us
who have dogs.
I don't have a dog
at this particular time,
but I love them.
But those of us
who have dogs and love dogs,
we treat them like children.
They're just four-legged
children with fur.
This is what you need.
Naomi Watts does it.
Snoop Dog does it,
so you know it's good.
-Okay, that's great.
-That tells you
about their client base.
That's good.
"Purple Rising,"
tell me about it.
You have it right there
with you.
-"The Color Purple."
You know, that's the movie.
-That is a movie.
-It's a movie.
-You had a friend in it.
-Yeah.
You know, I had a friend in it.
Also, Seth, back in the day,
I want you to know
that I was actually in it.
Now, if you blink,
you will miss me, but...
-I didn't know this.
This is very exciting.
-No, if you blink,
you will miss me.
But you know,
when "The Color Purple,"
the book is now
over 40 years old.
So they've had the book,
they've had a movie with Steven
Spielberg and Quincy Jones.
Oprah, first nominated
for an Academy Award
back in the day, Whoopi.
So "Color Purple"
has been around a long time.
Now it's coming up and it's
going to be a new movie
with Fantasia,
Taraji P. Henson, Halle Bailey.
So look, "Along For the Ride."
Look, there I am.
-Here, go over there.
Go over there.
-Okay.
-Look at you.
-I know.
So I was -- This is funny.
I was visiting the set one day
when Oprah was first starting,
and I was so fascinated
by all things movies.
And they said, "Do you want
to be in the movie?"
I went, "Okay."
So I was one of the extras,
but literally,
you have to blink
and put it on pause to see me.
But it's been around.
So this is the definitive book,
the behind-the-scenes stories
of how the movie was made,
the way the book was done,
Alice Walker.
It's great
if you love "Color Purple,"
and you do, audience,
and you do.
-And you do.
You got a sweatshirt.
-Okay.
This, I love.
Those of us who have children --
So you have "The Original."
Have you guys seen this?
Okay.
"Encore" for your child.
I like this.
-"Remix."
-That's great.
-Isn't this good?
-These are very good.
-I love this.
-"Mic drop."
Very cute.
This is my favorite one.
"A Fresh New Beat,"
when you have the baby.
-That's very nice.
-Isn't this nice?
-Normally, I
bring you matching pajamas,
so I tried
to change it up this year.
-I'll take it.
We're very excited about that.
By the way, we do wear
our matching pajamas every year.
And now we have these
lovely cookies.
-Who doesn't like to have
matching pajamas
in a family photo?
We have some of those, too,
on the list.
-So these are
Christmas and Hanukkah cookies.
-I love it.
Yeah, we got a dreidel.
We got a Christmas tree.
These are very nice.
-So we have the kit for you
that you can make it yourself.
[ Laughs ]
-Mm-hmm.
-You can do the icing
with the kids.
-Somebody laughed like
I wasn't supposed to eat these.
-Let me have one, too.
-Thank you.
And this is the whole kit
I want to show.
You don't just have to work
from scratch.
So this is...
-And they're soft, guys.
-Alright, there you go.
-So you get the icing,
you get the sprinkles.
You can do it
with your favorite children.
We like this, too.
-There you go.
You guys this is Gayle King,
everybody!
-Thank you guys!
-The cookies are delicious.
The full list of
Oprah's Favorite Things
is available now
at OprahDaily.com,
and will be featured
in the Winter 2023 issue
of "O Quarterly"
on newsstands now.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Late Night."